muy buenas es un encuentro aquí en el
centro de montpellier aquí a lo largo de
esta semana como preámbulo a esta cumbre
se ha dado este festival gastronómico
cultural que pone en relieve la cultura
africana esta cumbre en realidad pues es
organizada por la presidencia de la
republica petición presidenta
precisamente de emanuel la mano del
presidente de francia que quiere renovar
estas relaciones entre su país y el
continente africano y para esto pues ha
querido reunirse con los actores de la
sociedad civil a áfrica una de las
particularidades de esta cumbre es que
no hay ningún jefe de estado ni jefe del
gobierno africano invitado ahora algunas
representaciones diplomáticas presentes
pero esta vez no habrá ningún gobierno
presente y eso pues ha levantado
bastante suspicacias no ha gustado a
muchos gobiernos africanos de que no se
les haya tenido en cuenta en esto sobre
todo cuando se trata eso de renovar las
relaciones entre en francia y áfrica
relaciones que muchas veces han sido
dolorosas por ese pasado o colonial que
continúan siendo complicadas en parte
por ejemplo por esa presencia militar de
francia en la región del sahel donde
está luchando contra los contra el
terrorismo y bueno se da todo esto en
medio también de una situación
complicada a nivel diplomático con
varios países africanos hace unas
semanas fue con argelia y en la última
fue justamente esta semana ante malí
cuando el gobierno de ese país la junta
militar éxito convocó a la embajadora
francesa
precisamente por unas
palabras del presidente más con que no
habían gustado a la junta militar así es
natalia le preguntó qué ocurrirá mañana
cuando comienza oficialmente este evento
bueno pues es una jornada bastante densa
porque son seis temas seis ejes sobre
los cuales se van a girar las diferentes
mesas redondas los diferentes debates
del presidente marco no estará presente
a lo largo del día son temas que tienen
que ver con educación con democracia con
cultura restitución por ejemplo de
bienes culturales algo que viene
haciendo francia también en la parte
deportes igualmente también de eso se se
va a discutir así que como les decía
pues es una jornada bastante densa y
estos temas todo eso forma parte de un
informe que pidió el presidente bajó a
uno filósofo camerunés se llama así le
vende y es él quien en los últimos siete
meses pues ha visitado varios países
africanos ha debatido con la juventud
africana para saber cuáles son las ideas
que ellos tienen que pueden aportar
también un memorial memorial de agravios
de alguna manera de saber aquellas cosas
que están fallando en esa en esa
relación y precisamente como poder pues
avanzar en ese sentido y bueno fue
precisamente este señor así de bien
pues escogió a los doce jóvenes que van
a debatir con 7 manuel bajo en la tarde
de este viernes